افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بتدمير سياره
اوكرانيه كانت تحلق في اجواء شبه جزيره
القرن ونشرت وسائل اعلان الروسيه مقربه من
وزاره الدفاع مشاهد لتنفيذ هجمات بطائره
مسيره على مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه بالقرب
من بخمه كما قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ورئيس بلديه موسكو انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه اسقطت طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه في
استرا بمنطقه موسكو وفي كلوجا وفي تثير
شماله موسكو في وقت مبكر من يوم الثلاثاء
وكانت تحلق باتجاه العاصمه الروسيه من دون
تسجيل اصابات او اغراء
معنى من الصوفيانسك مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام ومن دونيت مراسله الجزيره رانيا
الدريدي مرحبا بكما وابدا مع رانيا وهل من
انباء
وتاكيدات وصيه لما يجري
لوصول هذه المسيرات الى شبه جزيره
القرم والاثر الذي احدثته
بدايه محمد دعني استهل بالحديث عن تطورات
الاوضاع في دانيسك حيث نحن نتواجد الان لا
سيما في حي كيرافسكي الذي تعرض منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى لقصف من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه السلطات المحليه تحدثت عن ان
القصف طال منطقه سيكانيه في هذا الحي نحو
الساعه الخامسه صباحا وهذا الحي كما تبدو
الصوره خلف محمد يعني الحق اضرارا كبيره
ليس فقط بالسيارات التي كانت يعني تتواجد
على مقربه من احدى العمارات السكنيه التي
طالها القصف بل وايضا يعني بالمبنى السكني
نفسه كما تبدو الصوره يعني هذا المبنى
مؤلف من تسعه طوابق والتوابق يعني العليا
منه تضرد كثيرا جراء هذا القصف وتجدر
الاشاره الى انه وفقا للمعطيات الرسميه
فان مدنيان اصيب بجروح خلال هذا القصف
احداهما بقي حتفه متاثرا بجراحه اود
الاشاره الى ان هذا المكان يعني خالي بشكل
كامل من اي تواجد عسكري هو حي سكني يعني
بكل معنى الكلمه محمد
على الاقل هو مباني سكنيه وسكان محليون
حاليا يعني يقفون في الشارع ينظرون لي
اثار هذا القصف فضلا عن ذلك يعني هذا
القصف هو ليس الاول من نوعه القذف
الاوكراني وفقا لسلطات مستمر للمنطقه خلال
اليوم الماضي ايضا لقي مدنيان حتفهما 11
شخصا اصيب بجروح بما في ذلك ثلاثه من
الاطفال
من الواضح على الاقل وفقا لما نشهده نحن
هنا ووفقا لما يصدر من معطيات رسميه ان
القصف يستهدف بالدرجه الاولى المناطق
السكنيه على سبيل المثال يعني تم ايضا
اليوم استهداف يعني منطقه جوارلفكا في
مقاطعه دانيسك تم استهدافها منزلين سكنيين
وايضا في ظلمه واخا تم استهداف محطه
للتصفيه الميناء المياه وقبل لحظات ايضا
محمد صدرت معطيات تتحدث عن ان القوات
الاوكرانيه قامت باستهداف مدينه دانيسك
مجددا الحديث يدور عن حيكوي عن هذان
الحيان وفقا للمعطيات الاوليه حتى هذه
اللحظه تم استهدافهما بقنابل عنقوديه نحن
نعلم ان الجانب الروسي كان قد حذر كثيرا
في الاونه الاخيره من مغبه استخدام هذه
القنابل لاسيما يعني مخاطرها على الناس
والدمار الذي يعني تقوم بالحاقه التحتيه
السكنيه وما الى ذلك اذا القصف الاوكراني
مستمر هناك قصف ممتاز واضح منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى لمدينه دانيسكو والمقاطعه